The Joe Rogan experience,
the lost civilization and pass down.
I deploy a concept in this book that I actually got from Richard Dawkins.
Richard Richard Dawkins is the author of the book called the selfish gene.
And he's not one of my favorite people because he's a,
he's a materialist reductionist and he doesn't believe in spirit or,
or any mystery in life that were just accidents of chemistry and B and biology.
We also has no psychedelic experience.
And he said,
no.
I did challenge him at a public event to go to go have a dozen sessions of
IOWASCA and still gas.
And once,
Oh,
just one would be enough.
But he has an excellent out because,
uh,
and sandy he's had,
he's had a stroke,
so he has a good excuse for not for not doing that,
but he's a clever man.
And one of his concepts that he's introduced into human culture is the concept
of the meme,
I think familiar with that word.
Genes are a physical reproductive mechanisms.
They reproduce themselves down the generations they replicate,
they multiply their passed on from one individual to another.
Memes are cultural objects,
cultural ideas that are passed on and replicate and reproduce themselves.
And what I see right across the Americas and right across the old world as well
is a set of meetings that involve the sky,
that involve the ground,
that involve geometry,
that involve notions of life after death.
Uh,
and I think the only way to explain these is that they have been inherited from
an earlier culture that was in some way connected with the ancestors of all of
these,
all of these cultures.
I think that's what we're looking at in the Amazon.
We're looking at a meme which was deliberately created once you mobilize the
population to start creating huge geometrical structures,
you are also facilitating many other possibilities that an organized population
allows.
I think that's what happened at got Beckley Tepi I think that's why they created
the Megalithic site there to mobilize the local population of hunter gatherers,
to give them a project to do,
to engage them and in the process of engaging them to teach them the skills of
agriculture,
which were,
which,
which are fundamental to any concept of,
of civilization.
And it's weird the way agriculture just suddenly appears in,
in Quebec,
the Tepee,
and there's huge agricultural mysteries in the Amazon as well.
Um,
may I share a couple of leaves messages with you before you do that though?
Can you pull up that image?
Uh,
from go Beckley Tepi of pillar was the pillar 43 43 in enclosure d I would like
to see that that guy holding that bag.
That is,
it's a,
the,
the bags are in a row along the top of the pillow.
Um,
it's pillar 43 in,
in,
in enclosure,
d at correctly.
Taffy.
Is there a,
an image of that?
Online is available.
Okay,
here we go.
Yeah,
there's that,
there's the bags in a row and a row along the top as the same sort of square
shape bag with a curved handle that you find on the earliest image of the pillar
of the feathered serpent.
And that you find,
no,
you have to go above that Jamie.
Um,
just a little bit higher up the pillar.
That was bad,
right?
Yeah,
right.
It right at the top there.
Um,
it's odd that the symbol crops up in,
in many different cultures and tends to be associated with some kind of
interpretation of those.
There's no mainstream interpretation of those bags.
That's my interpretation of those bags,
which I,
which I freely confess.
That's how,
that's how I read them.
I'm intrigued by the anomaly that the similar bag and turns up in the hands of
the quote sell collateral figure and turns up in Mesopotamia repeatedly,
um,
in,
in the hands of the individuals who are called the APP car.
Lou,
the,
the magicians of the gods at the beginning bringers of civilization and the
plume Serp and [inaudible] was a,
it's an Aztec card,
right?
And quest,
the quest.
So collateral is an Aztec is an Aztec God,
but,
but the Aztecs are him from earlier cultures.
The very fact that an image of the plumed serpent is given such priority in all
met culture tells us that that system of ideas was present during all Mac Times,
which takes us back at least to 1500 BC,
probably quite a bit earlier than that.
Where's the Aztecs are 1,580.
So there's 3000 years between the Aztecs and the Omex and that same system of
ideas is running through all of those cultures and the Mayans had a name for it
as well.
Cool.
Con and w,
what do you think that plumed serpent was?
I think he's,
it's very clear from,
from the accounts that have survived that what he's associated with a two things
in PR in particular.
One of them,
he's had god of peace.
He's not a war God.
Uh,
and the,
and the other thing that he's primarily about is giving the gifts of
civilization.
This is what you,
human beings need to know in order to move on to the next level.
Uh,
that is,
that is the function and the role of quite sarco Ethel and it's there are very
similar,
we could refer to them as civilizing heroes who are found in other cultures and
other locations or Cyrus in Egypt plays that role,
uh,
as a bringer of civilization.
There's hardly a culture in the ancient world that doesn't remember a time far
back in remote prehistory when some kind of supernatural or advanced human
beings.
And I prefer the latter,
that some kind of advanced human beings were involved in a project to
disseminate a civilization.
I mentioned the two no in the Amazon who,
who are big drinkers of,
uh,
of Iowasca,
the Takano have a fascinating origin myth.
Uh,
they say that they're an origin myth states specifically that their ancestors
were brought to the Amazon.
They were brought to the Amazon by a group of super naturals who included the
daughter of the sun and an individual called the helmsmen who steered the
serpent canoe in which this settlement mission in the Amazon was,
was performed.
And what these so called supernaturals did was they brought the ancestors of
Tucano to the Amazon and they showed them the best places to settle the best
places where they,
where they might find hunting the best places where they might create a village,
the best places for agriculture.
And then they left,
but they left them behind one gift and that gift was Iowasca.
Wow.
That's the story of the origin myth of the Chicano.
And it sounds to me rather like the other side of the story of that DNA signal
in the Amazon,
that a group of people were deliberately settled,
uh,
in the Amazon by human beings who they chose to regard as a,
as a supernatural best.
That's what makes sense of it to me.